first Indian said later and we also have
optimization starting today and we'll
have another talk about adversarial
example okay thanks
so this is lecture on generalization and
the fourth one the final one will be
either let me remind you of this picture
which I think is useful once again we
have a a question of when is it a good
idea or when is it okay to minimize
empirical loss if what we care about is
out-of-sample was expected so in order
to understand this we we introduce the
notion of an empirical process and the
way to think about this is is on the x
axis you have all functions you have a
fixed distribution P and so the blue
curve is it is a cartoon of
out-of-sample performance of all these
functions or the expected value of each
of these functions but what we have is
is empirical data and so we have an
empirical evaluation for each of these
functions that's what we can measure and
loosely speaking that some kind of curve
like that a red curve that's a sample
path as you go through all the functions
and for any fixed function the mean is
zero but with any realization you don't
get exactly the mean you get something
and if you take all possible functions
then the picture can be misleading the
empirical picture can be misleading and
in particular you might end up choosing
an empirical minimizer that completely
fits the data if the class is too large
but that's a overly biased
estimate and the actual expected value
is very high and you're just got unlucky
or lucky so once you once you decide on
some set G which is not really showing
here it's a smaller set of functions for
the smaller set of functions you hope
that the fluctuations of empirical and
expected control and so the that
supremum over class of functions is the
largest deviation between the blue and
the red curve that's a random quantity
and we're trying to understand that and
supremum that's the supreme of the
empirical process and and if that is
controlled if if within this window the
red curve is close to the blue curve
then it's okay to minimize empirical
risk right because the red curve is
close to the blue curve so then it would
make sense to minimize the over the red
curve that that's the empirical fit to
data and and then there for that the the
gallery on the blue curve is also small
that's kind of a cartoon way of thinking
about the uniform convergence and what
peter talked about is if we want to
understand the supreme among the
empirical process that's the top line on
the left then we might as well try to
understand the supreme of the Rademacher
process so that's a process which has
two sources of randomness the data and
excellence and these Epsilon's came
because instead of considering the
distance so to say the difference
between the red and the blue curve we
can consider the distance between the
red curve and another in sensation of
the red curve and so roughly up to a
factor of two that's a similar type of
distance and then signature ization
allows us to insert these random points
okay so why did we do that well it turns
out that the Rademacher averages or the
Rademacher process is easier to analyze
in many cases so often it's easier to
analyze and another nice thing is that
we can now work conditionally on the
data so even though the bounds that
Peter showed so far for neural networks
were data independent let me just show
you that you can get something data
dependent pretty easily so here is a
simple example you take a class of
linear functions this class will come
we'll come back to this class when we
talk about perceptron again so this is a
class of real valued functions which are
just linear functions indexed by W which
itself has a Euclidean norm at most one
and let's say the domain is bounded in
the Euclidean norm as well then it's a
simple calculation to show that
Rademacher average is rather mark of
complexity of this class of functions
conditionally on the data data is the x1
trace and at this well that's the
definition and then you take W out by
linearity outside of the outside of the
sum and that's just the definition of
the dual norm and so this quantity is in
fact equal to expected norm this is kind
of a random walk with increments X I
these are vectors but the length of this
random process cannot be more than
square root of the sum of the squares of
the increments divided by N and that's a
just a trace of the so you do get
something that is data dependent as an
upper bound on Rademacher averages and
you you wouldn't be able to get this
particular form if you're working with
the original empirical process the
supreme of the empirical process so
symmetrization really helps you to to
get things kind of faster to calculate
things fast
okay questions about this point I'm just
recapping what what we did last time
okay so now we turn to classification so
far Peter talked about uniform laws of
large numbers in an abstract setup now
we're going to turn to actually
classification and we'll go through a
few classical results on the VC
dimension of the growth function these
are in some case in some sense worst
case results and so it's up to you to
decide whether they're applicable or not
but it's worth knowing about these
results from the point of view of
generality okay so let me recall that if
you had a class of functions from X 2
plus minus 1 so think of these as
classifiers for cats and dogs the label
is plus minus 1 and the losses the
indicator loss correct or not correct
then we were able to write this
indicator as just 1 minus the product
divided by 2 so to say linearizing the
swarm and then it's easy to see that the
expected supreme of the Rademacher
process over the lost class so that's L
composed with F well we can just get rid
of the L ok so this indicator loss
disappears because it has this form so
that that's that's nice and now the
question is how do we understand this in
the in the classification case how do we
understand the expected supreme of the
Rademacher process as peter mentioned we
can just think of Rademacher averages of
the projection of the class of functions
onto the data so now we're conditioned
on the data x1 through xn are can are
fixed and now think of the projection of
F or restriction of F to the data
functions in this class F we don't we
don't care what they are we don't care
what their values are outside of this
data set so think of this as really just
a projection onto the
so that's a that projection is a subset
of the hypercube in dimensions and we
already talked about how if this
projection is small then things are nice
if projection is large then we can't
really do anything so here are a few
examples this is an example that Peter
briefly discussed take thresholds on the
real line X maps to indicate the next
less than alpha alpha is on a real line
so what would be the set as you go
through all the functions
that's essentially varying the value of
alpha the value of threshold and data
are now fixed what what kind of
signatures what kind of values on the
tuples can you get well you can get all
zeros right if all phase and then as you
vary alpha you get 1 0 0 0 1 1 0 0 0 0
and so forth right so you can only get n
plus 1 different values for the
projection the the size of the
projection of this class of thresholds
onto fixed data it describes a very
small portion of the hypercube the
hypercube is due to them vertices but
the projection is relatively small and
so it's clear just from this picture
that rather mark or averages are small
for a finite projection
you always get log size of the
projection divided by n square root
in particular Peter talked about the
Lubyanka Cantelli theorem about
convergence of empirical CDF to the
actual CDF so that gives you the rate of
convergence here's another example
suppose that a class of functions is
some class of functions but it's
parameterize by I K bits vector so hey
there is a K bit parameter now it's
clear that the size of the projection is
at most 2 to the K right X's are fixed
for any theta you have some signature of
the pluses minuses on these data since
there are only 2 to the K values for the
parameter that's the cardinality of the
protection so immediately you get the
random our edges are bounded by square
root of log of 2 K that's okay I'll put
some other back is divided by M okay so
very simple very simple way to kind of
get estimates on on Rademacher averages
and and it's nice that you can work
conditionally on the data um
how about in general you give me a set
of classifiers okay I guess here we
switch to 0 1 vs. minus 1 1 but the
growth function is defined as the
maximum size of the projection for any
set of data points in your domain so so
a question is how expressive is this
class if I get to choose and data points
x1 through xn and you get to measure the
size of this projection of the class how
many how many different signatures of
plus-minus wander in this case 0 ones
can you realize by your class on the
given data here that this should be
related to learning because if you can
realize any explanation of the of the
signs then then the
shouldn't be able to generalize at least
on that set of data points okay this is
a quantity this is now a data
independent quantity so we went from
something dependent to data independent
but again it's cleared because of this
log cardinality result that Peter showed
that random occurrences are always upper
bounded by log size of the printer this
maximum projection onto the annotated
set of data points and therefore the
same holds for the supreme of the
empirical process okay this is not so
important but it's it's nice to think of
it the size of projection is always
smaller than the cardinality of F which
could be infinite but as n goes to
infinity you you will get all the
possible signatures of all the possible
okay so what does the VC dimension is
just the largest size that the size of
the largest set X 1 through X D that
would imply a full projection Opoku q
peter mentioned this result that if in
your projection you can find that a cube
and that's an impediment to red marker
averages being small just because you
can align your Epsilon's with any vertex
of that hypercube and get at least the
constant from from as a lower bound it
turns out that this is the only
impediment to radical averages being so
if you cannot find a hypercube inscribed
in your projection then automatically
you have a small projection and that's a
non-trivial result in due to flattening
determining guess so let me state it on
the next slide at this point let's just
say that VC dimension of F is going to
be the maximum d such that there exists
X 1 through X D on which the projection
is a full projection of size Q and this
non-trivial result of application
running has also attributed to sour and
Sherlock says that if the VC dimension
is no more than D then the size of the
projection grows as the following
quantity and that quantity is better
understood as having a polynomial
behavior as n to the D type of behavior
whenever n is larger than D so here's an
interesting dichotomy of that before and
crosses D you have full cube or you
could get a full cube for your X 1
through X D but now as n crosses the VC
dimension you only have a polynomial
with a large size of the subject of the
hypercube the girls from exponential the
whole cube to just a very small part
which is a polynomial size and that's a
non-trivial result
kind of a magical result that Gabriel
gave rise to this
okay so here it is VC dimension D is a
single integer summary for the growth
function and again it's full cube until
you cross D and then it's just
polynomial this by the way just shows
that the quantify this idea that having
a large cube is the only impediment to
Rademacher being large as soon as you
cannot find the cube it's just
polynomial and the implication is as we
saw already is that for any distribution
P the supreme of the empirical process
is governed grows at the rate no more
than square root of d log n over D over
N so that is something that converges to
zero and therefore you have in form
convergence and in fact this is an even
only if statement so if if you're
studying uniform convergence with
respect to arbitrary distributions then
finiteness of the VC dimension
but for the Supreme of the empirical
process to converge to zero and kind of
the big elephant in this room is is that
supreme over P right so I if you know
nothing about the distribution then this
is kind of the right quantity it's it's
unavoidable quantity dimension is
unavoidable but in fact we often have
other assumptions and so in in a
particular situation this VC dimension
might be a very loose quantity think of
this as just an upper bound on
Rademacher averages which tightly govern
the behavior of the expected supreme of
the empirical process
okay so think of vc-dimension is just a
kind of a a nice and quick quick way of
getting a result about expressed
expressiveness of the class of functions
so for instance there's a useful result
of Goldberg and jerem 93 so if a class
of functions is parameterize by some
parameter theta that lives in in the
three-dimensional space
that should be
so a for each point X suppose that the
map from theta to the to evaluate the
function given the set of parameters
that map can be computed using
arithmetic operations comparison then
the VC dimension of the class is no more
than four times the P is the
dimensionality and T is the number of
operations so as long as as long as I
you have finite computational resources
in this sense you can't really go beyond
the a finite VC class from which other
results can be derived in particular VC
dimensions for neural networks any
questions about this dimensionality of X
think of it as a separate computation
tree for every X you do some sort of
arithmetic computation to work out what
f of X is for a given theta it's
important that the theater is a
p-dimensional real gotcha
I guess what I'm saying is that M
doesn't appear actively or probably to
you itself
no you can think of the RM is just being
an abstract space X and for every
element of that space you may have a
separate computation tree I I think we
were saying that
TT probably contains rapists it might
contain different effects that's not
true I think the place is that for every
X there's a separate computation tree
and and what's important is the depth of
that tree that's T all right the maximum
depth across all X's is not consistent
with what's written here but sure it
surprised that for each X the map from
theater
X comma theta can be computed in my
sketch that's exactly what it's
defending X is M dimensional M is very
large
yeah then that tree might be yeah then
that tree might be longer for a lot for
you to hear X what the whatever it is
right so implicitly if you're a separate
tree for every X sure so you could have
if none can be over the number of those
okay yes what we should think of we see
intuitively well it's it's it's a so
there are different ways to think about
this one way is
it's like when we think of parameters we
can think of parameters living in a
d-dimensional space and then somehow you
can let's think about covering numbers
so the covering number of a compact set
would grow as something 1 over epsilon
to the power D what what these results
imply is that for for a class of
functions the right dimensionality is
this nationality of the class of
functions even though they're not really
it's not even nothing not even a vector
space for T for a fully connected
network of them D is it I'm just trying
to think if that's like you count matrix
multiplication as one operation or is it
these are open right now with the oil
yeah it's just like the number of
revenue squares the result is no
requirements when T is like on the
ground ok so here are the results many
of them are from the 90s so if we have a
piece was this wise ok so if we have a a
class of functions which are neural
networks with L layers P parameters and
K computational units so what other
computational units in addition decay is
just a parameter that is
okay so if we have piecewise constant
nonlinearities which is not something
that we use you would get order of VC
dimension will be the order of the
number of parameters if we have rare
lose this is a recent result of Peter on
quarters you would get a VC dimension
something like number of parameters
times the depth all of these are tight
if we have kiss wise polynomial
activations then PL squared is what
appears and that's tight as well and so
that's paper width of Peter in the 90s
and if you have sigmoids than the VC
dimension is P squared times K squared
so so what is K squared in this case
this is the number of nonlinearities
through T London yards yes it's you know
the the sequin case is different because
it's like you're of making that model
with computation on the previous slide
with an exponential function yes number
of exponential functions is important
right so so in this in this case the
exponentiation is not allowed but once
you allow this then you can talk about
sigmoid and yes
could you comment or give some intuition
as to why in some cases you've got
dependence Annabeth and others don't
the piecewise constant cases the one
where you don't have dependents and you
know I guess it's just there's less you
can do with layers threshold units
that's the kind of intuition Mikey
thinks deeper this doesn't seem to
doesn't seem to help there I don't know
if there's a stronger intuition than
that it's interesting that these upper
bounds grow in terms of the depth you
know these boys constant is no
dependence piecewise-linear it's the
linear with depth and then if you get
the quadratics if you have some
curvature in the non-linearity all we
know actually is there's enough about
them squared but the best lower bound is
again in time del P so we have some
depth in it what's that bring us some
depth yeah so the way to get more peace
is some kind of bit extraction from the
weights if there's something where the
actual numeric value is positive or
negative is more important and once you
have even rhythms you can play all kinds
of tricks of extracting they or didn't
attend something
basically each layer of depth allows you
to expect the fit of the of the weight
so you depend not only just in a number
of ways with also the number of penalty
number of weights times number of bits
you to expect yeah I mean so extracting
bits is one technique and another one is
iterating iterating maps and I guess
yeah in both cases if you've got just
constants you don't get much power out
of those too much information and the
lower bound to P always be a good
expression that the yes that's right
distribute my intuition straight so in
cases where L doesn't appear the number
of layers so there's no sort of
separation between l and l +1 not
another snow right that's right so deep
shadow if if all you're looking at a
number of parameters then then you know
you could you can find cases where the
vc mention grows at least is the number
of servers and you always have enough
available more than the ignoring well
facts but are you saying that they're
presentational bar is the same are you
saying that the VC dimension is a little
busy mention yeah okay you're not saying
about the representation power like the
first case what you don't say that that
dependence is the same for Charlotte T
if representation pal means BCD what
functions you did represent like what
matters was talking about
right so I mean if you're thinking about
understood
the growth function things that's
alright but the number of the the size
of the table if you write it out you
know with with n entries then that is
suppose that definition of
representational power this is telling
you it grows polynomial in with this
exponent but if that's if you want some
other lotion you know if you go through
the proof cycads a breakdown in the
threshold case they go through it
they're finding the other cases yeah in
the threshold case does it and that's
also yeah but the last I guess the last
part that loves the number four you
still have separation results yeah but
for asar ginger but also because K
squared is so massive that you know P
squared case where it is always going to
be bigger than P elsewhere
okay so let's move on maybe one more
answer to a question that was raised
before intuition so you can try to think
of vc-dimension is the number of
parameters which sometimes it's the case
but that in general this is not the
right not the right notion so if you
look at signs of science sign of was at
Alpha X as alpha varies then the VC
dimension is is infinite but you have a
one-parameter family so it's you can
construct the examples where we just
have one parameter but an infinite VC
dimension so just be careful that VC
dimension is not the same as parameter
number of parameters although in these
cases it can be related okay so in the
at least and the ninetieth and maybe
even or other this prompt that the what
is this the the fact that the VC
dimension can be a large and especially
if you map things into high infinite
dimensional space they could be infinite
it's prompted a different study a study
of large margin classifiers and these
are the types of graphs that were
discussed in the 90s were very
reminiscent of recent graphs so this is
bagging this is a procedure where you
have the data set your sub sample build
a classifier sub sample again build a
classifier and then just average
bagging and what was observed is that
even when you fit the even if when you
get the error to be zero the
out-of-sample error can still decrease
this is boosting again the rounds of
boosting after just the five rounds the
the the classification loss in in sample
is zero but out of sample keeps
improving so the question was what's
happening from you know this is
something that's completely not captured
by these results and cannot cannot be
captured by these results
okay so you could express my apartment
like the safe box it doesn't like the
marching doesn't buy you I just by
projecting they're the problem many in a
different space so I'm not quite
following what what they were saying but
let me do the explanation and we'll come
back to your question so what was
noticed in these situations is that the
the margin does increase and margin
something that I will define on the next
slide margin is something that does
increase as you continue the iterations
and so this was proposed as a possible
explanation it works through a few more
snapshots this is from 97 it's a very
similar plot with neural nets where you
have a number you increase in the number
of hidden nodes the size of the neural
network and and the out-of-sample
performance keeps dropping and keeps
dropping and that doesn't go up and and
of course these are the kind of the more
recent realizations of the same
phenomenon where the error decreases or
it doesn't go up as you continue
increasing the size of the neural
network right this is the kind of the
final points after you've trained the
neural network for different sizes of
the neural network
Notty
there's a training procedure matter for
this plot I mean it's a CD but I don't
know how much how sensitive is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
showing the differences in saying oh
here it's a bit more this if you like
yeah I think I think this plots are for
a CD but as we said they're similar like
it doesn't matter if you look at food
great in this sense weak moments of we
have moments of work like for complex
algorithm say oh it's just image and we
didn't try to contact these authors okay
so the kind of a possible explanation
for the phenomena that was observed in
the in the 90s was proposed as follows
so in practice of course we compute a
real-valued function f and then we take
the sign as the classification right so
you train your own network that gives
you a real value and then you take the
sign plus minus one if the product of Y
and f of X is positive so the outcome
aligns with the prediction then F
classifies X correctly and this is the
notion of the margin that I was
mentioning before so Y times f of X is
the margin of function f on the point XY
and in the case of perceptron this
corresponds to the geometric notion of a
margin that it's a projection of X onto
the onto the W right and the alignment
with the Y but in general that geometric
notion might not make sense when F is
not linear what does it mean for X to be
far away from from the okay so you can
think of a larger margin as being more
confident in the prediction and in order
to have a large margin you might choose
a loss which encourages large margin and
and so one way to rewrite the square
loss is I guess just to multiply inside
to multiply the both terms by Y so you
get 1 minus y I f of X 9 and so that's
the same thing as the square loss and so
both of these are functions of the
product Y i f of x i right so that you
can in general think of this as a fee of
Y I some of the fees of
and the idea is that the VC dimension is
a very brittle notion it it checks
whether you get a plus or a minus
even if the value of F is just above
zero it's a very brittle notion that
goes out under goes after these fine
grained details of F which you might not
be important right so the question is
can can one get something that's based
on the complexity of F rather than
complexity of the sign signatures of F
on the on the data
that's a question so if you recall from
a previous lecture if the loss function
is Lipschitz even one Lipschitz then we
were able to relate the stream of the
empirical supreme of the Rademacher
process over the lost class so this is
lost composed with F to the original
without the law school functions we
erase the loss function is the
contraction property and we could apply
this type of thinking to an indicator
loss to the 0 1 loss just by writing the
loss as 1 minus y y prime over 2 right
but then what do we get we get we get
that the supreme of the Rademacher
process over el composed with sign of F
is bounded by radical averages of the
sign of F so we haven't gotten to F
itself we only gotten to the sign of F
and once you're here you're kind of
stuck with the VC dimension analysis and
this is the quantity that really goes
after these potentially minuscule
details of F so if for instance if the
class of functions F is very close to 0
but goes just above just below the signs
are still complicated but the real
values are not complicated right the
expressiveness of that classes real
values is very small so what we want is
actually the we want to end up with
Rademacher bridges over the class f
itself rather than sine of f that's
that's the
and to do that we go through the route
of surrogate law so so as a function of
Y times f of X you can think of Y f of X
this product.this is 0 the indicator
loss looks like that that's the
indicator of a mistake if F times y is
less than 0 you pay 1 otherwise you pay
0 and a surrogate is anything that
dominates anything that dominates the
the step function that's called a
surrogate loss and there are different
versions of the surrogate loss you can
think of the exponential that I
mentioned before here e to the minus
product or you can think of this ramp
function that that's in red so that's
just a ramp that interpolates from 0 to
1 at the slope of 1 over gamma and the
square loss is also a surrogate although
it's a weird type of surrogate where it
it is like that right so you start
paying with this surrogate you start
paying even if you're classified
correctly and the loss function is
trying to pin you down at the exact
value of the Y variable rather than just
the correct in terms of classification
okay but these are all surrogates and
the surrogate that we'll consider now is
is this ramp
the red one the ramp okay so that's the
definition of that ramp and the nice
thing about that ramp is that it's
sandwiched between the original
indicator loss and the what's called the
margin loss it's the proportion of well
it's it's it's it's one if you didn't
classify confidently enough if you
didn't give out a confident enough
answer so if if Y times f of X is less
than gamma you pay one and that's
written here so the the sandwich in
between the original indicator loss this
is the ramp loss and this is the margin
loss
from that we can conclude that the
probability sorry they they expected
validate this is the notation from a
process theory this the operator is the
expected indicator for the out-of-sample
performance of f is upper bounded by
expected surrogate performance of f and
the empirical performance this is the PM
does the empirical averages of f on the
data for the surrogate are upper bounded
by the empirical performance of the of
the margin portion of margin mistakes so
putting these together we have the
following result now of course the ramp
losses Lipshutz
and now we can apply the contraction and
get the actual real value at class F
right that's the idea before it wasn't
indicator loss was not Lipschitz we
couldn't apply contraction now the ramp
loss is Lipschitz we can apply the steps
of the the expected 0 1 loss which is
just the expectation mistake is upper
bounded by the surrogate c which in turn
is upper bounded by empirical p vertical
feet plus the contraction now this is
the Lipschitz constant of that loss
which is 1 over gamma and Rademacher
averages of the class and now we go from
the empirical field loss to the
empirical margin loss and that's the
proportion of margin mistakes made by so
that gives us what we want we wanted the
Rademacher average of the original class
f rather than sine of m and you can
think of this as using surrogate a loss
to turn a classification problem into a
regression problem that's wrong
and the vc-dimension is no longer
important we're not dealing with signs
of F anymore so you can't you can't make
this step but this step is still ok you
can you can just stop here and you can
say well if my cross entropy is small
then I do have a regression problem with
that
so here's an example take linear
classifiers
in possible infinite dimensional space
so gene doesn't matter anymore if you
did signs of the hyper planes then D
would matter but because we don't have
signs the dimensionality doesn't have to
come into play so if these are bounded
by one in the l2 sense then we saw
before at the beginning of this lecture
that the red marker average is bounded
by 1 over square root of N and therefore
I'm skipping a lot of details but with
hyper ability for all F out-of-sample is
bounded by the number of margin mistakes
that this function makes plus 1 over
gamma and 1 over square root of n let's
just compare this to perceptron what did
we get for perceptron we got this was 0
because we
Ultra so so well okay
now that this was zero but we had zero
here and we just had out-of-sample is
bounded by 1 over gamma squared times 1
over N square of this rate so indeed 1
when this is zero one can redo the
analysis with rather local run on
cartridges and get ok margin we know
that you just use random projection on
that space which projective space to
roughly on the or vice versa ambien
dimension doesn't matter
yeah basically then you'll get a little
dimensional space and realizes the sails
wrong you can use these dimension in
that space do you mean in the linear
case like right the way thing if the
margin is the geometric margin yes
Mitchell give respect yeah but whether
there's a general issue of imagine that
such a sure it was y times f of a just
for illumise linear 40 for linear that's
correct but this results is the general
result here is is for arbitrary classes
so one thing to note here is that the
statement is with high probability for
all F okay so I'm not talking about the
your particular F I'm talking about all
F in F now it's easy to turn this
statement into a statement where this is
replaced by the complexity of this F
okay so they can think of defining a
sequence of shells according to some
complexity of F taking Union bound
paying a little bit more but essentially
you will replace this by the Rademacher
complexity of the smallest F that
contains this little so that makes a
little bit more sense in in the context
of neural networks let's say you at the
end of the day you've trained your model
now the result holds for all F but
therefore it holds for your F that
you've computed and for that F that
you've computed it has a certain
complexity let's say in terms of the
product of the Frobenius norm as
describing yesterday and that is the
complexity that will appear here right
for that function that you've computed
just keep in mind that this result can
be easily converted
okay now these are somehow a posteriori
notions of generalization bounds where
after the fact you can compute this and
say well this is actually small and this
is small therefore that expected error
is small so it's not showing that the
zero one loss - the base is small
yesterday I described two types of
results and this is the second one but
in fact Peter showed that you can
convert a statement about minimizing a
surrogate loss into a statement about
minimizing zero one loss with respect to
the base that gives you the first mode
of the first type of the result that I
was mentioning so if you you if you
ensure that your algorithm minimizes the
difference between the expected few loss
so that's a but they just expected few
loss of y f of X and difference with
respect to the base which is defined
with respect to fee is small then there
is a transformation sigh that relates
the our target goal of getting a small
excess loss with respect to the 0 1 loss
back to the to that one like was a
complicated explanation but so that the
paper is by Peter Michael Jordan and
John McCallum
any questions about this where is the
proper view of the transformation what
does the property it has a certain
closed form that you can find them in
those two just defined in terms of the
surrogate loss sum function
transformation of the surrogate loss in
you know convex case if if you do
something sensible so have the gradient
defined at zero and pointing the right
way then then this inequality is
actually gives you something in the
sense that driving the right-hand side
to zero means that the thing inside so
that beggars that's called calibration
really if you do something on the
surrogate loss it gives you a guarantee
that you also doing something sensible
in zero one loss
okay so let's wrap up here a
classification problem becomes a
regression problem if we use a loss
function a surrogate loss function that
doesn't very typical too quickly we
replace the indicator lost with that
surrogate for regression the complexity
of a neural network is controlled by the
size of the parameters and not
necessarily by the number of the
parameters so that's the difference
between the VC dimension analysis of the
neural network and norm-based
analysis so now you can invoke all the
in this result now you can invoke all
the results that Peter talked about
about the size of the complexity of the
neural networks in terms of products of
various norms of the layers and more
generally what we've done is written
statements of the following form where
you have a surrogate loss and then some
complexity of F I think this is
replacing the Rademacher averages of the
class F and there is some interplay so
it could be that you you for a
particular problem you might be you
might be interested in optimizing some
other fee which maybe you give some give
up something here but then gain here or
the other way the other way around make
this smaller by increasing this so
there's some non-trivial trade-off that
you can play with just in terms of the
kind of real valid complexity of
this is a so the punch the punch line is
is that even though the zero one loss
might be flat you've fit the data
perfectly in terms of the science it
might still be a worthwhile to optimize
a surrogate loss function logistic in in
in the hope to get a better balance of
these two terms so that's an explanation
for why even after training all the way
to zero in terms of the signs you might
still keep improving out-of-sample when
you okay so let's go into the next
section I have about 25 minutes that's
good so in the next few sections we'll
go back to this object this is the
expected out-of-sample loss of our train
model minus the empirical was the
resuscitation loss of our model on the
same data on which it was trained and
what we will show is that the this
expected difference can be made small if
we know something about the algorithm
have had am not necessarily choosing a
erm out of some class but some other
properties of an algorithm so this
portion of the of the lecture is more
algorithm centered rather than thinking
about the complexity of the class F so
this quantity is interesting for at
least two reasons one as before as we
showed before if you want to understand
the excess expected loss of erm that's
upper bounded by that quantity exactly
and so that's why
removing the hat and going to the
Supreme of the empirical process but it
can also be written as a it can also be
used as a kind of a pass to rebound if
we can upper bound that then expected
loss of our solution is upper bounded by
the empirical laws which hopefully a
mystery we observe is small plus
something that is so there there are two
different kind of interpretations for
why we want to bow so I'll try to
discuss two approaches in the next 25
minutes
these are compression bounds is the
first approach and the algorithmic
stability is the second approach and
these are meant just as a entry points
kind of sketches or how to get
generalization
it setups other than uniform conversions
okay so let's let's go through a little
bit of a notation I want to denote a set
s by a set of z1 through Z and as s and
we'll make the dependence of F hat sub n
on s explicit for the purposes of proofs
so even though hat already is our
notation for the explicit by writing it
in the square brackets okay as before G
is our lost class that's L composed with
F and and we're gonna write G hat as
function and our solution and again
we'll write G hat and of s to emphasize
the dependence on this particular data
set okay so what is compression suppose
that the algorithm doesn't really depend
on all the training data okay so how do
we formalize this suppose that there is
some compression function C sub K which
selects from any data set s of size n a
subset of K examples is a map from the
set to a subset of that size
such that the algorithm if trained on
this data set s is the gives the same
output the same function the same
predictor as if it were trained on K
points with that subset of size K does
that make sense the definition makes
sense so maybe to keep in mind the
following situation where pluses pluses
here and the minuses here and you're
looking for a rectangle that contains
all the pluses and suppose this is a
realizable setting that this is always
possible then you can just keep you know
leftmost rightmost so there's a
compression of size
so you can throw out all the other
daytime you would get the same solution
with just those few examples
another example is SVM's
if there are a small number of support
vectors then the decision boundary is
just defined in terms of the support
vectors these are the ones that are
closest to the to the boundary and if
you threw out the rest of the data it
would be the same solution so that was
so yes yeah okay so maybe this is
confusing for the an algorithm is is a
way to compute the FN hat but what I
really care about is just the what what
does happen happens
it is it important that the compress set
is actually a subset of the training set
as opposed to some other key points
I believe it is important let's go
through the broken sea
ask a defender then or is it fixed um
say fixed for now yeah the bound will
involve K and n and so you should be
able to take K all the way to almost N
and divided by log and should be as far
as I can you can take this with other
questions questions okay so what's the
what's the idea that's what we want to
bound the out-of-sample performance of
our train the model by the empirical
well that's just the definition with our
notation and I didn't write the set but
right here this is the definition right
so the set a set s here it's
conditionally what we're fixing set s to
conditionally on this the drop set s
this is correct and this is the you know
so I just wrote out the education right
because it would be the same function
with the compressed set
so it's just by a definition of function
and now we're going to remove the
dependence on the data right we're going
to do it in several steps and the first
step is to remove the dependence on the
subset which subset is being chosen by
this compression scheme so I guess it is
important that this is a property so now
the we're taking a max over a subset of
the indices of sizes no more than K and
so S sub I is just the notation for the
subset in this file okay but maybe not
all subsets and have that property that
the loss is the same in the total and so
I'm saying that suppose that there is a
function such that suppose there is a
function for your problem at hand for
your algorithm such that this holds
was that was either well but there might
be only one subset of K elements such as
missiles
yes and so when you're taking the
maximum bound over all subsets shouldn't
you only do it over the subsets that
satisfy that oh it's an upper bound so I
know well I mean it's not gonna be loose
we already went to K and now we're
taking a Union bound over we're taking a
maximum over all subsets as long as this
includes the subset that you had before
that's fine it's it's only a log factor
away from
okay and so what is the idea the idea is
that the function can be compressed to K
points therefore it's its most out of
sample so the empirical average is
mostly out of sample it's in sample only
for those K examples on which it depends
so let's make this precise well you just
add and subtract other K variables
I guess this should be M but the Z prime
will have a you will switch the the Z's
on which the function depends to a fresh
disease and and we I didn't mention this
but we assume that functions are loss
functions are bounded between a and B
and so you're at most pay K over N for
that switch that's a single step but now
it's really a zero-mean random variable
that everything here is fresh so to say
and and therefore this is an unbiased
estimate of that okay
okay so we to maximum over a finite
collection of 0 mean random variables in
particular it behaves as B minus a over
square root of n the maximum is behaves
like log of the cardinality of that set
cardinality of that set is n choose K
for the choice of a subset of size K and
the bound follows questions it's a very
simple elementary argument so the
compression style argument limits the
bias it shows a limit on how how biased
the algorithm can be two at most squirt
of cablegram I don't know if anyone had
used this for neural networks but if not
maybe it's worth thinking about this
probably it's a different approach right
we never talked about a theorem or cost
functions from which the algorithm makes
the selection is a very abstract result
that says it as long as there is some
compression bias is about and notice
that when we had when we're working with
a VC class of dimension VC dimension K
that's roughly the bound that we've got
and so there is still actually as far as
I know I know open questions regarding
whether a compression scheme always
exists for a class of finite VC
dimension
so an example you have pluses and
minuses on the real line thresholds so
just saving saving these two points is
enough as a compression solution and so
K is equal to two very simple argument
that gives you the same result as in so
some other observations so compression
size of four hyper planes and D
dimensions there is always a compression
scheme of size D a partial set of size D
and so that matches the VC dimension
type of analysis but you can also get
the 1 over gamma squared type of
analysis through the perceptron because
you know you know the perceptron is a
separating hyperplane for that data that
is defined in terms of only 1 over gamma
squared elements you start with 0 and
you make at most one of our gamma
squared Corrections and therefore your
final hyperplane only depends on those
mistakes on the XY that and so that
gives you yet another compression based
proof for generalization
and it couldn't get faster rate with
sideburns and the last thing I want to
talk about this algorithmic stability so
that's yet another way of bouncing this
bias typically this expectation nonzero
but if if algorithm if your algorithm
has a certain stability property then
this bias cannot be too large and it's
very much in parallel to the to the
compression with a different notion so a
compression says that your algorithm
only depends on a small subset of size K
of the data points stability says that
the algorithm doesn't depend on any of
the data points too strongly it's
slightly different but very much in the
same vein right compression only depends
out of this data on the small portion
stability the output doesn't depend on
any of the data points too strongly
ok so this is kind of a standard thing
to do you you write out the expectation
with respect to the data of the
out-of-sample performance just writing
it out this expectation with respect to
all the random variables the function
depends on these random variables that's
the training data and then it's
evaluated the fresh point to Z right
there a new data point see that's the
out-of-sample performance in expectation
of you're always again the meaning of
this is the Train on this and custom on
Z on the other hand let's write out the
expected in-sample performance so that's
when you train on Z 1 through Zn and
then evaluate on Zi as well but in
expectation expectation goes into the
sum all of these are the same because
data are iid and that's something I
didn't mention the throughout these
lectures data iid so you can just think
of Z 1 right they're all the same so Z 1
is good enough so the the quantity is
expected in sample performance is just
expectation of when you
trained on Z 1 through Zn and evaluate
on Z 1 ok so let's look at the it's one
more step when we look at the
out-of-sample performance one like once
again you train on Z 1 through Zn
evaluate on Z because Z and z1 have the
same distribution we can just rename
them right so it's a trick that is very
common and we've done this before even
in the first lecture with perceptron you
just rename things right so z1 replaces
the one by Z and this becomes Z and now
we subtract the expected out-of-sample
and expected in-sample and now we're
matching the Z ones and what is
different is only the first argument
here is the fresh Z and here at z1 we
haven't done much except for rewriting
this but now this has a certain
stability interpretation if you know
that the function that didn't change
upon the change of one date one training
data point then that exactly gives you
the bound
questions about this
in fact everything we've written so far
is equality so this type of stability
and expectation the difference in
expectation being small is equivalent to
being able to bound the expected
performance by empirical performance for
your algorithm is only indicative of the
expected performance in expectation even
only if
now just we discussed this already but
you know bounding this expected
difference it only makes sense if you
can ensure that the expected fit to data
is small which is the case for these
neural nets so maybe maybe this is here
so there is a notion of uniform
stability which is much stronger than
what is needed so here we just need this
difference to be small and expectation
that's equivalent to what we want but
you can ask for a much stronger notion
which is in form stability which is to
say for all the data all the training
data not an expectation but for all the
training data and a two other data
points Z Prime and Z if you trained on
the original data set and evaluated on Z
and then trade on the data set where you
swap the eighth element by Z prime and
then evaluated on Z if this difference
that's kind of a stability notion
because if that output is no more than
beta will say that the algorithm is beta
uniform in a stable this is a very
strong notion and it's clear that this
is sufficient for getting this in
expectation
that's easy to see and in expectation
that's an easy argument and then this
really nice work by vitaliy and and and
yon Wondrich just this year showed that
also you get really sharp hyper ability
statements if you assume any stability
to get sharp concentration statements
for that defect of empirical inspector
and maybe the last thing that I will say
is that this is a result of busca al
safe in 2002 is that the ridge
regression Colonel Ridge regression
which is a solution to fit the data with
square loss plus penalized by Norman RHS
space if as long as the ridge of the
kernel is bounded which is usually the
case in our problems then the solution
is what this algorithm is baited in from
this table with beta on the order of 1
over lambda N and essentially this is
the intuition for that is you're
optimizing a strongly convex objective
strong convexity comes from this F
squared so you've got a bunch of data
plus the penalty and now you're changing
one data point here in this data set
replacing about something else that
shifts the optimization landscape a
little bit it's a convex shape just a
little bit by order of 1 over N and the
minimizer should be closed right the
minimizer should be closed because it's
a strongly convex objective this the
spin of innovation ensures the seen from
there
here comes the building and I think
ninety will also discuss this in his
talks it's linear and Kappa or is it
square root of Kappa oh so that's
squared so I think it's linear in cation
up crazy
I will let me not go through the proof
but it's really that that is the proof
okay sorry I think I will stop here am I
correct on time I think it's a good
point to stop and Peter will start with
vocal methods the general idea here is
that we are going beyond the analysis of
erm so beyond the analysis that based on
here from those of large numbers it's
good to know but maybe there are other
approaches that are useful to you in the
analysis of deep networks or whatever
and there were some interesting results
in local methods that Peter will present
and then he will talk about
interpolation that's going to there's
analysis of a margin and there's the
choice of the loss function becomes
interesting and Peter has worked on that
which loss functions will give you will
drive the MIS classification boss - or
get lost
yeah I'd like the people on that phone
but but yeah it's not it it's much more
copy patent and that's last case where
in some sense everything obvious works
but if you if you can get the expected
surrogate lost down to its minimal value
that the base value then then you know
that implies you could do well for
classification it's it's not so easy to
design for instance a convex loss that
works in the multi-class case works in
that sense that once you get that the
expectation of this convex loss down to
its minimum value of possible functions
you know that that ensures that you get
the bad risk
I mean there are plenty of examples you
can come up with where that is true
great it's not something not so
straightforward some some apparently
reasonable choices don't work
generalizations of SVM loss don't work
in it
civility yes
we often laugh they're using something
like cross-validation then what happens
to cross validation with us with a fresh
set of data
but then I mean with kpop things are
murky right because well I guess I
should say that this is a deterministic
result for for any fixed lambda this
holds there is no in this statement
there is no nothing about randomness so
whatever lambda is there that's the
lambda here so in that sense it's okay
right but but but then if beta is now a
random quantity itself now it becomes
oh I'm done it's open
[Applause]